how did you discover your passion or
find your career were you exposed to it
or was it trial and error as child
rights advocate Marian Wright Edelman
said you can't be what you can't see
fortunately we now live in a time when
emerging technologies may help us to
solve this problem for the past two
years
I've been developing an extended reality
program that enables middle school
students from across the country to take
on the role of a marine biologist even
if they've never seen the ocean as one
7th grader who recently completed our
program sad I could see myself as a
scientist because I enjoyed this game
this feedback really excited me because
too few students do see themselves as
scientists a 2014 study showed that 57
percent of eighth and ninth grade
students said science isn't me
coincidentally also in 2014 I met Mandy
Holford a marine biochemist and Lindsey
Portnoy an educational psychologist the
three of us shared a passion for getting
students excited by and comfortable with
science we thought about how we could
give children the most realistic
experience of a scientific career we
discussed the research that showed that
students felt comfortable taking risks
when playing games so the three of us
started an educational games company to
bring science to life virtual reality
seemed like a low-cost way of increasing
access in addition academic research has
shown that virtual reality may lead to
increases in learning retention this was
perfect for us as we wanted to be in
schools so that we could reach the most
number of students possible particularly
students who have been underrepresented
in science so with funding from the
National Science Foundation we began
developing our extended reality program
that combined virtual reality with
personalized digital journaling we
worked with teachers while developing it
to ensure that it would fit seamlessly
into existing curricula and empower
teachers to use cutting-edge technology
in their classroom we designed the
virtual reality for Google cardboard
which requires only a smartphone and a
ten-dollar VR viewer made of cardboard
with this inexpensive headset students
are transported to an underwater
expedition students use their digital
journal to write down their notes to
answer questions to construct models and
to develop hypotheses students then go
to the virtual world to test their
hypotheses and see if they're accurate
much as scientists go to the field or on
their in their careers when students
return to their digital journal they
share their observations claims
reasoning and evidence the students
written answers and virtual interactions
are all updated live and an educator
assessment dashboard so that teachers
can follow their progress and support
them if as needed to give you a better
sense I'm going to show you a little bit
of what students see this is the virtual
reality and when they're underwater
observing the flora and fauna this is
the digital journal where they're
constructing their models based on this
abiotic data to show what they expect to
see here they're supporting that with
qualitative statements and this is the
educator dashboard that shows progress
and enables students to see the students
answers as they go when we were creating
bio dive again we really wanted to focus
on access so we designed it to require
only one phone for every four students
we also knew how collaborative science
work is so we constructed the experience
to only be solved through collaborative
teamwork as each students is an expert
in a different geographic location given
that these children's brains are still
developing we limited each experience to
last a maximum of two minutes and
finally because we know the importance
of repeated exposure for internalizing
knowledge we constructed by our dive to
take place over five class periods we
started piloting bio dive in 2017 and 20
schools in New York and New Jersey we
wanted to see students as they were
using this new technology in 2019 now we
are now we are now piloting in 26 states
what we have heard from teachers who
have katate our program it was a nice
way to show ocean dynamics without the
luxury of actually being there since we
are at Ohio it's pretty mind-blowing the
students were totally engaged but what
really gives us hope is what we're
hearing from students I like to what
felt like I was there it's interactive
and a fun way to learn it really gave me
realistic examples of how these
organisms appear I could see myself as a
scientist because it seems really fun
our feedback wasn't always so positive
when we began developing we started off
by asking students what they liked what
they didn't like
and what they found confusing eventually
we began asking what they wished they
could do their feedback gave us concrete
items to build in to be sure that we
were including student voices and what
we were designing overall what we have
learned is that this is the beginning of
a new platform for giving students both
voice and ownership in deciding how they
want to have impact in their careers we
focused on science because we know we
need scientists to help us solve our
current and future challenges but
virtual reality could support students
in any area how could we support
students in exploring all of their
desires with these eye-opening
experiences and chances to learn from
primary sources could we create vr for
inexpensive headsets that lets them be
immersed in oral literature or in
critical moments of human history
extended reality has the potential to
change the trajectory of our children's
lives and lead them to careers they
never imagined by giving them the chance
to see what they can be thank you
[Applause]